c'est juste un huit c'est une petite
chose ce n'est pas beaucoup mais c'est
vraiment puissant
IAL
oui
et puis euh
la qualité ici est tellement meilleure
et le prix je veux dire est trop cher dans
la rue c'est plus cher et moins
de qualité
[Musique]  les
cannabinoïdes et les terpènes disparaissent en quelque sorte
avec la chaleur les terpènes ne fonctionnent pas
bien non plus lors de l'ingestion
au moment où lundi a frappé,
nous étions euh vous savez que nous commencions à manquer
de produits
[Music] [
Music]
étranger il
y a une nouvelle installation de culture pour le
cannabis légal et ils le cultivent et
ils cultivent des trucs très puissants parce que
l'odeur est très forte
et je  je n'ai aucun problème avec
quelqu'un qui veut faire pousser de l'herbe ou
faire l'une de ces choses, c'est juste
proche de mon programme de traitement et quand
quelqu'un est en convalescence,
l'odeur du cannabis active en fait une
partie de son cerveau là où il '  tu
vas avoir des envies
[Musique]